hey guys i'm off the grid for august but
brian stelter is still an unlikable
potato
to understand why so many republicans
have abandoned democracy you have to
hear the poisonous propaganda what do
folks in the reality-based reality base
reality-based media do in the coming
weeks biden secret emails this is a
classic example of the right-wing media
machine when we're not able to say that
hunter biden's laptop is a story worth
pursuing you say we're not allowed we're
not able who's the people stopping the
conversation who are they is it possible
to make fox news viewers change their
minds about key issues just by having
them change the channel entire media
companies essentially exist to tear down
joe biden can we have an honest
conversation about gas prices has the
coverage been out of proportion out of
step with the american public too much
of the u.s media chatter is distorted to
the point of being dishonest dana
milbank here's his column for the post
this weekend and he says he has data to
show that the press has turned more
negative against biden than the press
was against trump what do you think
about that does it ring true to you
trump might have committed treason what
does putin have on trump the u.s
president possibly working for the
russians is president trump a racist is
the trump presidency a criminal
presidency trump and some of his allies
are promoting a hate movement against
the american press why does sarah
sanders still have a job is it time for
newsrooms to think of new ways to convey
trump's lack of credibility you might
say the media hasn't earned your trust
either okay look up the stats for
yourself there's no way to tweet
yourself out of impeachment impeachment
impeachment impeachment impeachment uh
what i hear on fox is that the media is
obsessed about impeachment impeachment
impeachment impeachment impeachment
impeachment imagine just imagine if
fox's right-wing host talked about trump
the way they talked about barack obama
dealing with hardship actually makes you
stronger that's what governor cuomo said
earlier today that's what i'm going to
teach my kids right now at home